hello I thought I'd tell you about all
the attention I get from blockchain
which monitors my daily movements my
friends and I love block teams new
shared network oh it's a bit like being
on social media a tomato knows have
toughie candidate gain trust once you're
with the block cane crowd it's easy to
mingle if we tomatoes also like to feel
that our data is safe blockchain
tightens the lid increasing that
security and it has a data validation
protocol that guarantees a system
virtually impregnable to any naughty
business the peer-to-peer network be
centralizes and streamlines the process
by eliminating intermediaries block
chains culture of transparency allows
you to see right through us
so we've absolutely nothing to hide and
the data from all our transactions is
locked
no one can delete or modify it even if
they want well won't grow and wherever
we decide to travel within the food
supply chain you can easily trace us
[Music]
you could even see on which farm I was
grown what I was fed from where I was
processed before landing on your
supermarket shelves blockchain enables
the identification of safety breaches
shielding consumers from potential
hazards instant access to data such as
on trade volumes or delivery times
provides clients with greater market
transparency smart contracts enable
transactions be automatically activated
by your preset instructions blockchain
streamlines the management of the supply
chain by eliminating useless
intermediaries uniting the physical and
the digital food worlds is one of the
many key challenges that blockchain or
any other digital technologies used for
this purpose currently faces blockchain
is a young technology not yet fully
delivering in terms of performance or
scaling out the capacity use cases need
to be developed to decide best
architecture options and security
measures blockchain of the significant
improvements in an agreed sector that
merits being explored thoroughly